a suspect in California accused of
attacking a conservative activist at
Berkeley last week officially pled not
guilty as his victims attorney revealed
concerns about his past
listen to this mr. greenberg over the
past couple of years has had numerous
incidents yes filed several lawsuits
against landlords for charges that were
later dismissed by the court he's also
had a restraining order filed against
him by a former roommate almost a dozen
lawsuits that I've uncovered that this
man is involved in she goes the one to
say firearms confiscated restraining
order gets them three felony charges in
a misdemeanor charge
Michael Knowles is the host of the
Michael Noah's show and joins us now to
react Michael thank you for being with
us why aren't the Democrats why are they
so silent on to us
well the trouble is this particular guy
is obviously a wacko he's a thug he's
got a long history of this the trouble
for the Democrats and for the left is
that he is emblematic of a larger
problem this isn't the first time this
has happened at Berkley this is a
problem all over the country the issue
is the left redefining speech as
violence well what do you make of the
president at CPAC where he pulled the
fella who was attacked up on stage and
then he said essentially that he was
going to come up with some sort of
executive order pulling federal funding
from colleges that don't support free
speech this is very important the
William F Buckley Jr program at Yale did
a survey 81 percent of college students
believe that speech can be a form of
violence and so what do you do to this
form of violence either you start it off
yeah you turn it off that justifies
violence against conservatives and we
saw this two years ago at UC Berkeley
Eric will speak all the time
well that's right yeah they love having
me there at Berkeley Eric Clanton this
community college professor hit
conservatives over the head with a bike
lock and what happened to him three
years probation and so President Trump
at CPAC he said well is there gonna be
justice served here I will have to wait
and see and you know what they're saying
this goes all the way up to the freshman
class in Congress they're intolerant way
of disrespecting their own leadership
it's they created this monster now they
can't control it there is a little shot
in Friday here when you see these this
generational shift among
rats in Congress and I think
unfortunately they thought as a tactic
they could hurt conservatives to define
speeches violence to censor people and
now they're seeing the fruit of that
ideological you think the president was
right to bring him on stage the victim
and point him out at sea fact absolutely
this is so important we've known this
for a long time that politics is
downstream of culture President Trump
made a key aspect of his campaign
stopping political correctness stopping
censorship stopping violence for speech
and if we don't get that fixed we're not
gonna fix any of our other political
problems well on the good side Berkeley
did come out and said that the attack
was reprehensible Michael thank you for
watch good to see you
heading back to California now hitting
the plane all right good luck to you